today I'm gonna talk to you about a
programming language called Nordic rated
well as the recurse center again my name
is ahmed abdullah um so to understand
why I create this language first need to
understand that I'm from Sudan a country
where the first language or the main
language is Arabic and I moved to the US
when I was nine years old and I realized
that I would have never learned to
program if I didn't learn English when I
came here but in the year 2013 I came
across a post on Hacker News by Brooke
programmer here in Brooklyn called
Ramsay Nasser and he created a an Arabic
program programming language called Club
and the club means heart and it's a
functional Lisp based programming
language and I thought that wow this is
so cool it'd be great if like kids
around the Arab world had a language
they could use to learn programming
because to learn to program in English
it requires like a lot of English
proficiency like you have to understand
you know Docs and tutorials and stack
traces it's not like you know a minimal
amount of English you need to know to
get started in programming and this is
at the same time when everybody is like
jumping onto you know code Academy for
kids and all these things let's get
everybody learning to program and where
I'm from in Sudan to learn to program or
to have this amount of English fluency
requires a lot of privilege you have to
be like wealthy to go to international
schools if you go to like good get a
really good education in English and so
I thought it'd be a great experiment you
know take a language like this and make
it more mainstream but my one thing
about Ramzi an officer's club is that
and this is my ignorance at the time is
that it's a functional Lisp based
programming language I'm like oh this is
great but it'd be nice if it was like
imperative you know algo based and
thankfully that was like an ignorance I
had at the time about like you know a
functionalist based programming language
but you know thank thankfully for this
ignorant because it led me to start this
project so Noor is an imperative algo
based programming language that I
created specifically thinking about
myself is it that was the little kid if
I was you know high school or middle
schooler
you know what would like be natural for
me to learn and this is a sample program
in noir I think you know I'll tell what
this program does but in case you can't
we'll walk through it anyways and so the
first line in this program says the coup
de chelly v1 to 100 which basically
means that you know for each thing in
the range of 1 to 100
and then the second line is check take
the number in the for loop and then
check if it's mod get them all three
value of it and so there's a function
invocation an assignment expression and
then the third line is just print the
number in the for loop and then the
third thing is check if the mod three is
you know equal to zero if it is is
clearly divisible by three print that
out print or print fizz if it's
divisible by five print buzz and then
the final parts to this you know program
here are the key words a bus which in
Arabic means like the end or the end and
in this for in this program I make a
call to a function here on the second
line and that function is just you know
get the mod with three of the number and
this is a function in nor and so the
function starts off with instruct a
worker you know and I try to make it
like this child like you know silly
language because I want to be like more
natural feeling and then you say you
give it the function name then you give
it the function arguments that it will
take and then you say to do because I'm
like a little kid I kinda want to
understand it as you know tell something
to do these things for me and then you
have the function body and in this case
I take the argument that was passed in
I'm Ottawa three and I store the result
in a variable called done or D and then
I returned that and so that was a you
know fizzbuzz ignore and i won't be able
to get into the internals of how i
created nor but i'll just tell you that
i used tool called Peggy is which
creates a compiler for you and it's a
really nice tool if you want to you know
create your own small DSL you should
check it out but one thing that sort of
came into a question while I was working
on this is how do I go about choosing
keywords and Arabic is like a big
languages you know very there's a lot of
variety to it and there's classical
Arabic there's modern Standard Arabic
and there's my own dialect of Arabic and
if you know if you don't understand it
the trees kind of something like this
and it's an approximation that you have
classical Arabic which is like a really
old Arabic going dating back to the
seventh century and then you have
dialectic Arabic which is what people
use on a day-to-day basis this is well
like me my mom talked with and
have modern Standard Arabic this is what
like official court documents are in
this is what news is in like Al Jazeera
they want to reach a wide audience so
they'll use this very formal Arabic
that's not particular to anybody but for
Noor I especially used my Sudanese
dialect because I was think about myself
is like what would I would like really
get me started on this and just to show
you a map of all these dialects and how
they vary on you know I'm from Sudan and
so this is the area where my dialect is
really prevalent and but you know
there's different dialects across North
Africa in the Middle East and you know
when I never got public some people who
really liked the fact that I use my own
dialect some people you know thought
that I was Egyptian because they're
trying to you know triangulate my where
I'm from based on a few key words and
it's kind of hard to do some people I
thought it was some like the Gulf and
I'm not from the Gulf and some people
really didn't like it some people are
like oh I'd be grateful to use like real
Arabic that's okay I knew they were
coming so but my goal or the reason I
intentionally do this anyways because if
you go to like the Middle East and you
listen to an Egyptian TV show I send the
Egyptian Arabic dialect if you listen to
a Syrian song it's in the Syrian dialect
so all these like media and artists like
export their own dialect so I'm kind of
like I'm gonna explore my dialect here
and so but really if the general
question is like is a programming
language supposed to be like this
generic tool like a court document that
should follow strict guidelines or does
it the programming language reflect the
aesthetics of the creators behind it and
the thing is like whatever language
you're using there's no like right or
wrong about the syntax is reflecting
whatever the people in the language
community behind it chose to do but also
during this experience I created newer
using on the browser using Peggy I yes
and initially I wanted to do it in
Python and I was gonna make it as a
desktop app and when I created a
downloaded Kitty which is a GUI
framework in Python and I started and I
created my editor and I started typing
into my keyboard and the Arabic text was
showing up all broken I was like what
the heck is going on maybe I'm missing a
plug-in maybe I need to download
something something just didn't make
sense and that's what I really came to
learn about how Arabic text is rendered
on your computer there's actually it's
not a handle
the operating system or whatever that
you your framework that you're using has
to handle it for you so I went to a fund
deep dive about how all that works and
I'll just show you how that is so when a
user types Arabic or when there's when
you see encounter Arabic text in a file
you have to run it through an algorithm
known as the buy die algorithm which is
at Unicode bidirectionality algorithm
then you have to reshape that text and
then you finally get a nice-looking
Arabic as for how the Unicode
bidirectionality algorithm works so
Arabic is a right to left language so
the Unicode by des algorithm specifies a
base direction or a line direction and
this is like this bottom long red line
here specifies the direction that the
text will flow in when it's rendered as
the user is typing it and then for every
single word I has its own direction so
this word this line right here says Bank
Bank on 2018 in New York City and the
terms Bank Bank on obviously flow from
right to left because they're every
keywords but in Arabic we read numbers
from left to right so the visual cursor
as the user is typing in a number has to
start flowing from the left to the right
then when the user types in Arabic word
again the cursor the visual person needs
to jump back to the end of the line and
start flowing from right to left and if
they type in English word it starts to
flow again from left to right so I was
about to like implement my own ever
consider but it's just like this is like
it was out of scope because there's a
lot of rules to handling by eye but as
you know it's good to learn and then the
other thing that you have to do when
handling Arabic text is that you have to
reshape it so Arabic letters don't take
the same form as they do in English like
you know you have in Arabic letters have
to be connected and they take a
different shape depending on where
they're at in the word um so in this top
line I have the letter the Arabic letter
h h h space h and the way this actually
gets displayed is like so below so the
letter h looks like this when it's in
the initial state looks like this when
it's in the middle state and then it has
a different look in the final state and
you have to reshape it and uh there's
more to reshaping than just simply like
looking up the letter and where it
belongs there's also these things as
ligatures Arabic certain Arabic
ligatures are mandatory so if you see
two letters you know
look up the initial and final forms but
you have to look up there's a precedence
where the ligature takes has to be shown
and this is more to every text reshaping
and by die but this is just sort of like
one of the some of the nuances I came
across when it comes to rendering Arabic
text but if you do that all correctly
you finally get to see nice flowing
Arabic text that you can read from right
to left and when it comes to by die it's
also an algorithm that applies to Hebrew
Yiddish or do Persian and a host of
other Arabic or host of other
right-to-left languages but when I was
look doing research for Niraj trying to
like look at like what did old
mathematicians use in their like math
works with a lot of programming ties to
math you know in some really close ways
and I was trying to think like what what
did like I'll quiz me who's a guy who
created algebra or he's known a lot for
his you know for algebra what do you
like he used in his textbooks and that
crime I came across the term chez which
is like which means thing which is like
a term I use in everyday Arabic even now
and in my fizzbuzz program this term is
like right here it's the value in the
for loop that iterates with and it turns
out Shea is how we get the letter X in
math like you know if you went to school
here for mathematics they're always like
you know find X or Y is x squared plus X
equal 1 you know plus 1 it turns out
comes from this like word Shea way back
when so this was like you know a fun
random fact I'll leave you all with but
thank you for your time that's all I
have
[Applause]